you guys met when you were 15 and 16
yeah how old were you when you were
married 21 21 22. so would you say at
that age you two were fully confident
making the choice this is it I'll never
be with anyone else I'll never crave a
sexual War be curious about exploring
that 21 and 22. I was extremely
confident we've only ever been with each
other and we waited until we were
married to have sex just so excited to
have that commitment of it's you and me
there's nobody else that I want as we've
been married it's just been more
solidified and even more confident
probably than I was then in this episode
I sit down with my husband and Amelia
and Matt a couple that practices
consensual non-monogamy living in Bali I
came into the relationship knowing that
I wanted to be non-monogamous I'd say
the first two years of the relationship
were probably the most challenging for
me just because it really felt like I
was relearning everything I'd ever
thought I knew about what love would
look like I'd say our communication is
better than many of the monogamous
couples we know friends who have had sex
with people that they are close with
that they often feel a sense of
afterwards that it wasn't actually
meaningful do you ever feel that way
it's almost like an extra extra topping
or something so if we're gonna do it
outside of the relationship we want to
make sure it's done really well with
integrity and empathy and compassion oh
my biggest concern would be raising
children so if you're gonna purposely
enter into a relationship that has a
higher chance of you splitting up I like
to look at risks that's just the way my
brain works Amelia and I have been
friends for almost a decade and though
we don't see each other often because we
live on opposite corners of the world
we've stayed in touch over the years and
I was excited to share this conversation
together with very opposing perspectives
on intimacy relationships and sex we
come from polar opposite life
experiences Andrew and I have only ever
been with each other intimately our
marriage vows were based in a lifelong
commitment of growth and unconditional
love through the hard times and the easy
times Amelia and Matt recently
celebrated their love in a
non-traditional marriage ceremony after
dating for five years they value freedom
self-expression and evolution as both
individuals and in a partnership what is
the purpose of sex I think it's to
awaken Consciousness for me I guess I've
had a lot of sex but that one point was
like it was something transformative do
you feel like your sex can be as deep
and intimate with someone you just met
versus the person that you are so write
or die with the person you're in love
with you've been through thick and thin
I've been really interested recently in
learning more about like female biology
it's a lot of research coming out that
illuminates the fact that women might
benefit more from multiple sexual
partners for us it's not a question of
how can we make monogamy perfect the
reality is infidelity always happens it
has since the dawn of time I kind of
look at it as this seeking the next
Thrill Is that always the best thing for
your life oh let's try a threesome let's
do a foursome it sounds very
transactional is sex meant to be with
one person committed for Life as a
sacred Soul tying experience or is that
unrealistic and is there value in having
multiple partners at the same time or
separately throughout your life or is
there really no one best way and it
really just depends on the person what
are the implications for society and
children and ourselves that and more is
what we get into today enjoy our
conversation
okay guys I'll be the first to admit
that I love pretty things so if I find a
product that nourishes me and looks
beautiful on the kitchen counter I am
all in anima Moody herbals does just
that they carry organic wild crafted and
ethically grown Botanicals in the most
beautiful packaging from Elderberry
syrup and adaptogenic mushrooms to
spirulina chocolate protein teas and
collagen booster powders every vibrant
and medicinally potent remedy is
packaged in eco-friendly packaging a
recyclable glass or biodegradable bags
it was founded by Costa Rican herbalist
Adriana ayalas who uses over 200
different sustainably grown herbs from
around the world to create intentional
products that contain zero fillers
binders or flow agents everything is
made in the U.S with certified organic
wild crafted and sustainably harvested
plants and herbs in a vegan and
gluten-free kitchen I love their High
potency Elderberry syrup which is double
extracted it's adaptogenic anti-viral
organic and wild crafted perfect for
supporting healthy immune function so
use my code ln20 for 20 percent off just
click the link in my show notes to get
this deal from an amazing company that
supports Fair Trade Practices Beyond
organic farming education and small
farmers to create remedies that benefit
people from all walks of life I think
before we begin I want to preface what
two consenting individuals want to do
should be free to do what they want this
is more just a philosophical question on
is one more optimal than the other you
agree with that yeah
okay so can you guys share a little bit
about your story what led you to
non-monogamy and how you guys got
together we met five and a half years
ago on a dating app we quickly kind of
realized that because we were living in
two separate parts of the world that may
be dating exclusively or it would be a
little bit of a challenge I guess I was
living mostly in Hawaii and Matt was
living in Indonesia so we kind of
started out casually dating like a
little bit long distancy but still a
little bit open and just kind of
allowing each other to you know hey I
might not see you for three months so
let's stay in touch but um we'll check
back in when we're close to one another
and then yeah quickly we discovered we
wanted to live together and spend most
of the Year together for the last five
years or so and pretty much been open or
ethically consensually non-monogamous
since the start
I think we've had we've had we've
evolved through I guess I came into the
relationship knowing that I wanted to be
non-monogamous so it's been there's been
some learning Curves in evolution and
creativity that we've had to apply to
our relationship but on the whole it's
been an amazing journey and yeah
couldn't think of anyone else that I
would want to do the journey Journey
with and when he presented the idea to
you when you guys met has that been was
that something you had ever considered
before and what led you to deciding that
okay I want to do this it was nothing
I'd ever considered before nope I
definitely grew up traditional you know
like beliefs around marriage finding the
one
um having children having a family so I
think at first my immediate reaction was
wanting to respect his wishes and his
beliefs because I don't think you
mentioned Matt was in a 14-year
monogamous partnership with the mother
of his children before dating me
so he when he came forward and said you
know I'm pretty sure this is how I want
to live my life and this is how I enjoy
dating and connecting with women my
immediate reaction was I'm gonna be the
woman that changes that I'm going to
change you so that you don't want to um
you know date anyone other than me
and then I think um slowly I started to
introduce myself to like reading
material and different books about
non-monogamy and I started seeking out
some people on the internet who were
practicing non-monogamy and just
learning a bit about it and then
obviously through personal experience
and us
um like I said being a part for such
long periods of time quite often I
realized it's kind of fun to be able to
go on dates and do things when I'm not
with him in person and still be able to
maintain the love and the relationship
and so it became more comfortable for me
and but yeah definitely a huge learning
curve and I'd say the first two years of
the relationship were probably the most
challenging for me just because it
really felt like I was relearning
everything I'd ever thought I knew about
what love would look like what a
partnership would look like and
um yeah it's because I think we created
a relationship we didn't really fall
back on trying to put out of construct
it in anything that we saw externally so
everything was sort of as we were going
through the evolution of the
relationship we were trying to configure
it to best suit the individual self but
then for the individual to come together
and function and relate sensitivity and
unconditional love and listening and all
those things the best of the best way
that we could yeah
people listening what
what polyamory and
okay yeah I mean like I said we'll be
able to speak today from like personal
experience we don't represent the entire
non-monogamous Community or polyamory
everyone's different and that's like the
probably the number one thing we can
share is everyone's going to do
relationships differently whether you're
monogamous or not of course so we
totally recognize that I'd say
um from what recent research I'm
learning is polyamory is essentially I
used to believe it was you know dating
multiple people at the same time now
there's a lot of people who believe that
polyamory is pretty much like an
umbrella statement of anyone who
identifies as non-monogamous
so non-monogamous
um non-monogamous and poly I don't know
when we tell people we're open we're
we're ethically non-monogamous or
consensually non-monogamous meaning you
know we are each other's primary
partners and our relationship always
comes first or it currently comes first
and foremost and then we do have the
opportunity to date other people outside
of the relationship
um Paulie I guess could look like that
but I believe mostly looks like maybe
you have a wife and also a girlfriend or
you have a husband and also a girlfriend
or a boyfriend on the side so it's I
think maybe pursuing more than one
serious relationships at once yeah I
know I think the identification of what
we portray to other people
is I don't know there's a stigma
attached I think with polyamorous and
and open relationships and like
sometimes we don't date anyone or see
anyone for almost a year don't we
sometimes if we're just working on the
inner stuff as individuals so yeah it's
I think it's we do try to keep
everything creative and not attach
anything to it yeah open for us I guess
yeah ethically non-monogamous but I hope
that explains it yeah it does I'm
curious what does monogamy mean for you
guys no no it means well I think of it
as like a marriage thing once we're
married we make a lifelong commitment to
each other to be with each other for
life no matter what
um matter what brings Good Times Hard
Times I'm committed to her and she's
going to be my only partner sexually and
that I connect with on that level for my
whole life and or her whole life and not
even just sexually but any kind of
intimacy totally you know like deep
intimacy yeah
um for us our story we've only ever been
with each other so it's a very
interesting difference that we have
between our couple's relationships
because most people are going through
life with serial monogamy where they're
dating one person maybe sleep with them
and then date another person separately
sleep with them but we've only ever been
with each other we've been together for
20 years and we started dating we were
15 and 16 years old and we waited until
we were married to have sex so we did it
for six years until we got married and
now we have the rest of our lives to
deepen our love through that way that we
did it in the beginning so I think to
get into all the things we want to touch
on what problems do you guys see with
monogamy I guess through my experiences
with monogamy uh and having children
within monogamy I just feel that I lost
myself just in the upbringing of
children there was like so much focus on
raising children without concentrating
on the self and then communicating that
with my partner that individual
evolution of self-awareness and all of
that kind of evokes for me that was the
reason that I didn't want to go down the
same road as that's why we've gone
non-monogamous because yeah because I
think I lost myself and I know my
partner at the time long-term partner
she lost herself and then when the kids
were not dependent on us anymore we kind
of didn't know who we were and we didn't
know who each other were and I think
that's what we're very conscious of is
to do individual things to keep the
individual self evolving through
connection that's my best way to explain
it I think yeah and can you all do you
feel like you can only do that through
sexual experiences with other people
people you can't do that in a monogamous
relationship or was it something that
maybe you guys didn't do that you could
have done in a monogamous relationship I
think if we had been aware of it we
probably could have done it within
monogamy but then you've got to not
expect the other person to to meet you
at some point maybe halfway of
developing that self-awareness and
wanting that growth for themselves to
evolve through that growth but I think
we just were so the children can
consumed as so much of our time that we
just didn't have the time to sort of
take a step back and evaluate our own
evolution
so that's like I think that's really
important if if monogamy is is a choice
then it's good to be able to step away
and I don't think you necessarily have
to have other deeper connections with
anyone else
just it's all about yourself evolving
but I guess for me through my
experiences it's been more to diversify
myself it in reflection in connection to
other people it's been beneficial to
broaden that peripheral on on connection
just from past experiences having the
same social group just to diversify that
just so I could learn
through experiences and and real people
and Gain real knowledge let's see I
don't necessarily believe that you know
there are all these inherent problems
with the monogamy for me personally and
I've I really
trans long-term monogamy because I'm
still quite young and I met Matt when I
was 24 so I'd only had really one or two
serious relationships before then which
were both monogamous
I just don't believe monogamy should be
the only social Norm I feel like for me
as I'm exploring this lifestyle and
meeting other people who are a part of
this community in this way of living I
just see the benefits so much so as much
as I see that there are benefits in
monogamy and non-monogamy and
um yeah I just think that it should be
an option that's on the table and people
are more aware of and I don't know I'd
like to believe there's like a spectrum
with monogamy actually there's a doctor
Tammy Nelson who calls it the monogamy
Continuum so it's like your monogamy
your version of monogamy maybe on the
farthest left point of the Spectrum
which maybe you you guys may relate to
of only us forever only together maybe
you know we don't talk to anyone else we
don't send messages to anyone else we
don't flirt with anyone else or whatever
that's our version of monogamy and then
there might be someone who you know it's
the complete opposite of the spectrum so
I just believe that there's room for
everyone somewhere along that spectrum
and then it shouldn't just be so black
or white if you're either monogamous or
you're Paulie and you're probably having
sex with 100 people a year or something
like that
so yeah I mean I have witnessed
beautiful monogamous relationships and
been you know part of them families and
myself in small ways but yeah
non-monogamy is just what I'm currently
experiencing for the last five years and
it definitely feels rewarding enough and
beneficial enough for me that um I do
feel like it's cool to be a little bit
of an advocate just for this way of
living and
that it's an option especially for women
I think it's really cool to talk about
especially for women what do you mean by
that oh well I think mostly like in
society's eyes or in mainstream Media or
Hollywood it's men are these big sexual
beings with testosterone and they have
this huge sexual appetite and I think
women have it just as much as men and
that you know often men are given more
leniency when it comes to sex and
cheating or infidelity or extra pair sex
or you know whatever you want to call it
and
um yeah I believe like based on female
biology and just my personal preferences
and who I am and the way that women have
sex and the sexual appetites we have and
the desires we have and our libidos I
just believe that there are more options
for women who yeah want to have a strong
a healthy relationship and a strong
sexual like appetite and they want their
needs to be met and I don't believe it's
possible for everyone to have their
needs met in monogamy so okay you guys
if you aren't using non-toxic cleaning
products in your home it's time for an
upgrade Branch Basics is my new favorite
line for a One-Stop shop of all the
cleaning needs for your family using
products that are baby and family safe
free of fragrances hormone disruptors
and harmful preservatives is a
non-negotiable for me and the fact that
it's all plant-based and saves waste is
an added bonus as well switching to
non-toxic and fragrance free cleaning
products can relieve headaches allergy
asthma symptoms and also provide eczema
relief their concentrate is used in
different dilutions to create all the
cleaning solutions then just refill the
bottles when you're out it's simple and
environmentally friendly one bottle of
concentrate makes three all-purpose
cleaners three bathroom cleaners three
streak free cleaners three Foaming Hand
washes and 64 loads of laundry along
with being sustainable their products
are hard working and range from cleaning
the kitchen to toilets and even laundry
and stain removal their starter kit
includes all the bottles you need
including the concentrate and oxygen
boost setting you up for success for
your new non-toxic cleaning routine so
use my code ln15 for 15 off all Branch
basic starter kits you'll be so happy
with the result and making the switch to
non-toxic and sustainable cleaning
products they are amazing you guys you
don't want to miss out on this deal
oh my biggest concern would be raising
children obviously divorce rates are
high in both in all relationships
whether it's uh same sex or different
sex or monogamous or whatnot but what I
have read before that most open
relationships end in divorce marriages
and divorce so I think of the children
more than more than monogamous
relationship somewhere in the 50 so it's
open marriages end in about 92 percent
so if children are involved then it
becomes a different different for me so
that'd be the main problem because
generally speaking when parents don't
live together and the kids are being
raised by one parent or the parents are
separated it generally outcomes for kids
aren't as good kids do better when both
parents are at home so if you're gonna
purposely enter into a relationship that
has a higher divorce rate and a higher
chance of you splitting up then it
doesn't seem like I like to look at
risks that's just the way my brain looks
works I look at statistics and like okay
well if I'm more likely to get divorced
then why would I do that when I want my
goal is to be committed to her and then
obviously coming into my family and
raise the best kids we can so that's
really my only concern with open
relationships is if you have children
are you taking into account
though that you're maybe increasing your
risk of having of separating or the
relationship not working out if it's too
consenting adults with no kids and
what depends on what your goals are if
your goal is if someone's in an open
relationship or they're in a
relationship and they're considering
opening it I would be why are you
considering open it uh and then if your
goal is to stay together for life I my
concern would be well you're doing
something that is less likely
statistically for you to stay together
in life but if your goal is just let's
see how it goes we're just taking a day
at a time that I just don't see any
problem with it yeah so I guess that
leads into the question of is there a
benefit to for life because maybe for
you guys I don't know you can tell us if
your goal is to be together for life or
not or is it kind of you know if we
don't end up together for life that's
okay every every part of life has its
seasons and
you know it's not necessarily a negative
thing to go through but for us our
commitment to life is like being
tailored for life is it's similar it's
kind of like your your marriage vows
like a vow is something very sacred and
meaningful and big and the vow to be
together for Better or For Worse that
there's got to be hard times because
everybody's messed up you're never gonna
find someone that's just it's easy
forever because there's no relationship
like that where it's just always easy
forever because we're all messed up
we're all inherently not perfect so the
for Life commitment is look I'm gonna
stick with you even when you're not at
your best like you'll stick with me when
I'm not at my best and the goal is
having a growth mindset to always be
growing and evolving together to be the
best versions of ourselves
and I think there's something to be said
about having that stability in life with
someone that is committed to you for
life as opposed to if I'm not good
enough like you may bail you know and we
are interrelational beings and so maybe
you might argue that there's a benefit
to having these extra relations intimate
relations with multiple people but for
us there's something so sacred and
special about each other's bond together
that when things are hard and we're
willing to grow from that that's what
like makes us stronger like our love is
so much deeper now than it was even
seven years into our relationship which
I couldn't have imagined or predicted
because I thought seven years into our
relationship that we knew each other as
best as we possibly could but that's
just not the case and actually when you
go through hardships and come out of it
I feel so much deeper love for him than
I did before so I think maybe at
people's experiences of bad
relationships either with their parents
or with themselves
you know what is the underlying thing
there and I think often it could be if
one or both are not willing to grow and
evolve for the better you know and that
makes it really hard especially if you
are willing to grow and evolve but the
other is not so that's definitely
difficult you know but
yeah so that's where I'm at okay that
makes sense what are your thoughts yeah
I think uh that Evolution process is is
so important and we focus differently on
unconditional love and freedom as the
foundation of our relationship like you
Emilia can't do any wrong I'm there
whether the emotions of jealousy or
insecurity within me are triggered at
points and vice versa we just get to sit
there and we get to work through these
emotions and I guess at the start of our
relationship jealousy was one of those
things that there was a reaction at
times even during our times of
communication that somebody would react
in a not enough not in a violent way or
anything but just in a just in that
insecure way but we've over time we've
evolved to be able to watch our emotions
and yeah I think that's just been such a
beautiful thing to be able to have the
experiences we have which would break up
a monogamous relationship but just to
sit back with unconditional love for
somebody for an individual's experience
and vice versa and and that to us seems
to be the growth aspect yeah I like the
honesty part of it like it's great
because a lot of monogamous
relationships people are so worried like
if they're having feelings for someone
else or tempted or do wind up doing
something inappropriate there's so much
fear that the relationship will be over
as a result then they hold it in and
they lie and then the relationship
deteriorates because there's dishonest
dishonesty in it so I think that one of
the main Pros I don't know if that's if
you would agree is the honesty Factor
yeah obviously monogamy you can be
honest too
yeah yeah yeah we've sometimes I have
like an innate maybe it's like an
instinct to want to go on a date with
somebody else and other friends that I
have that are monogamous won't be as
open as to speak about that to their
partner but then we've got friends that
are open and they'll say the same thing
so it's funny the conversations that you
have with friends that are in monogamous
relationships versus people in open
relationships that will just blurt out
anything that's sort of moving through
you or feels like a something male
instinct or and I'm sure females
experience it too just those things that
sometimes you you keep under wraps
within a monogamous relationship because
you don't want to offend the other
person but I think we're at the point
now where we can just say and it's a
beautiful thing to get to the point
where we are where we can say whatever
we're feeling I guess the instinctual or
we need to have a certain experience we
can just say that we want this
experience and and then negotiate it or
navigate it from
from from this point of unconditional
love yeah yeah
absolutely I mean I personally grew up
my parents were divorced when I was two
so I was raised by a single mom and then
spent our weekends with a single dad
basically so I never witnessed healthy
communication between parents and I
didn't really grow up much around
healthy mer you know healthy
communication between friends parents or
anything like that so I'd say arguably
like our communication is better than
many of the monogamous couples we know
probably yes our honesty and trust with
one another and ability to communicate
our emotions our emotional awareness
like we've put ourselves in so many
testing positions and experiences where
like you said we've had to come out on
the other end or we've chosen to come
out together on the other end and
absolutely we feel that deeper sense of
love and connection and compassion for
one another and if anything I feel like
I've never known a partner this closely
because there's none of that none of the
fluff to hide behind or none of the BS
or the lies or
um like you said that you know maybe you
have a natural you're attracted to
someone else or just little things I
feel like because of this relationship
container that you know we choose to be
and I really feel like I truly know you
and I feel very seen and known and and
heard as well and I feel like my
personal growth you know from when I
started out in the relationship with
Matt to thinking I'm gonna be able to
change you I'm gonna get the exact
relationship I want I know exactly what
I want and it's pretty much what
everyone else wants and you know I want
to have the cookie cutter like style and
the husband that loves me and the
children in the house and I feel like
I've been able to get to know myself so
much more and what I actually truly
desire in life and not just maybe the
repetition of what I see in society or
friends wishes or desires
and yeah I feel like our my
communication
um yeah it feels like it's it's tripled
my growth personally and
um yeah just learning everything
basically from scratch again and then
learning it it feels like so much faster
than many other people because we've um
you know we've allowed the opportunity
for these challenging situations too
role in our I don't want to say everyday
lives but in our lives you know as a
non-monogamous couple yeah yeah and as
for what you said about children which
is a little bit a while ago but I
obviously don't have any children yet so
I can't speak on it but we talk about
raising children together of course all
the time and it's something we'd love to
do and Matt already has two amazing
children who are very familiar with our
circumstance and fortunately they're
incredible and they have a great
relationship with both of us and I look
forward to being able to have children
and just teach them that you can love
whoever you want and we're here to
support you and you can love differently
and we're here to support you love
differently and if you want monogamy
we're here to support you and if you
don't that's okay and there's space for
like I said there's that there's room
for you anywhere on the scale and our
love for you is unconditional and we're
here to support you always and there's
actually a lot of research coming out
now because it's
obviously as time goes on but long-term
studies of children who were raised in
completely non-monogamous families from
the time of birth so their entire
adolescence were spent in non-monogamous
homes and I think the doctor it's
Elizabeth Chef or Ellie Chef as she goes
by but she's doing incredible studies
right now interviewing thousands of
children and pretty much across the
board you know children are saying that
they felt they had more adult role
models in their lives growing up in
non-monogamous families they had more
people to turn to for advice and if they
had their feelings hurt or they wanted
someone to connect to they had
um more adult supervision which they
obviously probably weren't thrilled
about but more adult supervision in the
home and then just the financial aspects
of many non-monogamous families lived
together in one dwelling and shared
income shared finances shared expenses
so there's a bit more financial
flexibility for the families and the
children to be able to experience more
and you know be able to travel more and
things like that so there's some really
interesting research coming out about it
but I I can't speak from personally it
sounds more like polygamy sounds more
like polygamy because if you have
somebody in the multiple people in the
home that's a lot different than like oh
I'm gonna go on a date with a person and
not being a like a serious relationship
with them right well I guess many
long-term non-monogamous relationships
or you know whatever you want to call
they do choose to live together it is
quite common so like like polyamory
polyamory yeah so is that something you
guys are open to we always say we're
open to anything yeah we're always like
what's going to happen what's going to
happen yeah we always I think because
we've moved sort of shifted away from
the society we live in a Eastern culture
we're vegan we've sort of shifted away
from the society's constructs
and we just want to sort of delay a lot
of them from Western society and not
that we want to move into the ideology
of the East but we'll take like little
bits of this little bits of the west but
then ultimately create our own wives
that hopefully don't look like anybody
else's I think that's the ultimate goal
and be like and be happy and yeah I mean
we can always
shift things around and do different
things differently and if they don't
resonate or they don't work out then we
can change them back or change them a
different way but I think that's the
beauty of not living within that within
what societies has told us we've got to
eat this we've got to relate like this I
think creating something totally
different and yeah we always talk about
it be like do you want another husband
or do I so yeah we just we kind of muck
around and with with the way that we
relate and as long as love and freedom
is the fundamental Foundation of our the
way that we relate to one another and to
the people around us with kindness and
compassion and and also the way we eat
and consume food it's yeah life should
be life should be cool so I'm really I'm
I'd be interested to see this that
you're talking about I'm skeptical of it
because knowing that the higher you're
more likely to get divorced if you're in
an open relationship than even just
monogamous which is already bad reads I
wonder like what the sample size was and
I'd just be really interested to look at
it after they show me afterwards totally
and then there's two things taking on
piggybacking onto that I really want to
get into the topic of what is the point
of sex like is it sacred or is it just
for what is the point of it to you guys
um maybe we can go into that that as
well but the first before that let's say
you your relationship is open and you
decide to have children and you're just
giving birth and you're in the
postpartum phase
would you keep that part open I know you
can't really say oh yes this is exactly
what we do because you're not there yet
but I just we know from experience how
vulnerable and sensitive that state is
totally and even with your example of
what how you feel like your love is deep
and an open can you imagine what that
would be like if you know your part this
will be the moment when your partner
would be if the relationship was open be
like peace I'm gonna go sleep with
someone else because you know you can't
right now right like you're recovering
from birth and you have a newborn and
like what are your thoughts on the
vulnerability of that because to me
something that I find so manly and
masculine is the protectedness of the
part of my husband you know that he is
there for me 100 and only me and he it's
almost like to me it's a biological
experience of even even the sacredness
of birth right like the problems we have
in our medical birth system and other
people handling purchase the the husband
being there to help you with that baby
born and that bond that you have from
this is our partnership this is sacred
it's you and me ride or die type thing
totally versus if it was open like
you're not giving me what I want right
now I'm gonna go sleep with someone else
to fulfill my needs it feels more
selfish than it is selfless totally so I
think for me your guys's perspective
it's more selfless to just let someone
sleep sleep with who you want because I
can deal with my own triggers of
jealousy or whatnot but is it possible
it's actually the opposite that it's
more selfish to not be committed to that
person and give to them because for us I
can't even imagine sleeping with someone
else I have zero desire to go sleep with
anybody else even if there's someone
that I might find attractive there's no
desire to oh man I really wish I could
go sleep with that person right now or
it would be great if we could go you
know be intimate like it's the the Deep
intimacy that I find from arc our
commitment is part of what makes sex so
great but yeah so I've touched on a lot
of things but what are your thoughts on
that cool I guess I'll answer the
postpartum question yeah um no I think
like I said we come first our
partnership I always say like I feel so
fortunate with non-monogamy because I
feel like I get to have my cake and eat
it too it's like I have the deep love
and the support and the partnership and
the intimacy and the stability and the
security and we would never do anything
like that like that would be a hundred
percent
unimaginable you know it's really
insensitive yeah absolutely so that's
not something no we wouldn't we would
never I mean obviously you know but no
we would never um even imagine the
intention is never to hurt one another
or like I said we always consider one
another first so even before we go on a
date or meet someone for a coffee or tea
or even you know initiate a conversation
online we'll communicate that with one
another first and check in how are you
feeling about this or we always consider
you know ourselves and our partner first
so of course having children you know we
talk about it all the time and the first
40 days and things like that we have the
shared vision of we want to be together
we want to start we continue with family
and grow a family and compassion and
sensitivity for one another is like at
the foundation of our relationship so so
if one person does have a problem with
it then like what is the condition is
there that can is it unconditional like
okay you're having a problem so I'm not
gonna go or is it oh this is your
problem that you're having a problem so
you need to work on that in that
circumstance yeah or just any the
circumstance you gave of we always check
in with each other so if one person is
having a problem what's the scenario
there oh yeah if I say to Matt hey I got
asked out on a date and I want to go and
you know on Friday night are you cool
with that and he says I actually was
hoping we could have a night together or
I was looking forward to spending time
with you sure 100 I'll cancel the date
or I'll postpone it if you feel
comfortable with that or yeah it's
really
um yeah I think you know we are very
considerate of each other's emotions
sometimes I'll react personally and be
like Oh I thought we were gonna do this
or you know and I'll think about it and
I'm like actually we could do that the
next night and if he wants to do
something then I can you know I can
actually get over it or allow it or but
no it's oftentimes it's
um right it's just considering each
other and yeah prioritizing the bond and
the connection we have and making sure
that our needs are being met as a unit
together before we yeah
seek externally for yeah probably if I
was to speak up and say if I if you were
going on a date or something and it was
I'd be like make sure you ring me when
you get there make sure your message but
just so you know that just on our meal
is safe or in safe wherever she's going
on a date yeah whether it's in public or
whether it's it's someone else's house
that's all I need to know
and then yeah I don't think I would say
oh I'm feeling really insecure or
jealous you shouldn't do this it's more
of a thing go and enjoy yourself Express
the love that's in with you within you
explore yourself
pleasure everything and but just yeah do
it safely and make sure that you get to
where you're going
so do you have something Sarah can I ask
a question so to me it sounds like sex
is more transactional than it is like
Soul tying because like what it what are
your thoughts on sex is it is it
something that's oh it's it's like going
and playing it's like bowling with
somebody like you go out you go out and
you bowl and then you go back to your
husband you bowl with a friend you know
or is it is it a soul tie is it this
sacred Mind Body Spirit experience if
it's with someone that your lifelong
committed to versus someone you just met
a couple days ago or a week ago or
whatever what do you feel like your sex
can be as deep and intimate with someone
you just met versus the person that you
are so ride or die with the person
you're in love with you been through
thick and thin with like what do you
think about that
well first I feel like it's worth
mentioning like we'll go on maybe let's
say we go on 100 dates and out of those
100 dates we're not probably even
as much as kissing the first 70 people
like we're not just out trying to sleep
around and get it where we can it's
right absolutely like absolutely
intentional and
um yeah of course we want to feel that
connection before we explore in any
intimacy or
um yeah you want to feel safe you want
to feel attracted to them you want the
chemistry to align absolutely and um I
do feel that we
have found ways to almost like enhance
and maybe sustain our incredible
connection and sex life because I mean
the reality for us at least the reality
for me and maybe for you is and for many
women and men I don't know if you guys
have ever heard of the term limerence
before it's like new relationship energy
yeah yeah the chemistry the butterflies
right that so now there's studies saying
that women usually experience like a
tremendous decrease or decline in their
limits in the first two to three years
of a monogamous long-term relationship
and for men it's five to seven years
so yeah we've been able to still you
know have this incredible partnership
have amazing sex have each other love
each other be intimate and then also you
know I've been able to be honest and say
oh you know I met someone out on the
surf or I met a guy and there's a bit of
a Vibe and I might go grab dinner with
him and then maybe a few weeks later I'm
still hanging out with him and say to
Matt I'm kind of interested in exploring
what it can feel like to have an
intimate connection with him and
um no it's not it's not probably the
same level of sex and
connection but it's still beautiful and
I think I always come back learning
something about myself or about the
situation that I can then bring home to
my partnership with Matt and say oh you
know I was thinking about this and this
came to mind and or I really enjoyed it
and it was great and I kind of feel like
I got this like I got it out of me and
maybe I'll do it again or maybe I won't
but if anything I'd say it comes home I
come home appreciating more the
connection we have and the partnership
and the chemistry and
[Music]
um yeah that's why we don't really often
ever do sleepovers because usually we
just love sleeping with each other so
much and so we feel we feel that same
level of connection and or maybe not the
same but we feel a version of that level
of connection and deep like intimacy
with one another and and we probably we
attract different people as well like
you attract a different kind of male and
I guess I attract a different yeah
female and a lot of the people I connect
to are deep into like tantric and
Kundalini and I think when you have sex
with somebody that understands a
Kundalini in the The Awakening and the
evolving through that and the the
slowness and the the way to to more be
your pure self without any of the
constructs applied to the identity you
become this within Kundalini and within
tantric you become this pure version and
and I think
through the evolution of our
relationship I'm attracting a lot of
women that are wanting that same
Kundalini tantric
uh connection so and which is a
beautiful thing I mean those teachings
you can you can really get to know
yourself and get to really connect with
other people as as we do as well so
so yeah you want to try it man what do I
think sex is yeah what do you think yeah
yeah I'd be what is more of a sacred
Bond I mean my
my belief system is just different like
I I believe I have more Christian
beliefs so my belief is there's one the
ultimate design for sex our creator
designed us to be with one person for a
reason
uh sometimes
you may like question those reasons uh
but I feel like the main reason is to
protect the family to protect the
relationship and to deepen the bond with
your partner and I don't have any
experience of being with someone else so
it's like we're coming out from very
different
places like we've only been together
obviously so it's really easy for me to
just kind of see it like well this works
great for us like it seems like a
no-brainer you know I it uh it aligns
with my belief system as well but I can
see how when you have different life
experiences you know serial monogamy
sleeping with multiple partners before
you find the one person you want to
marry how it could be possibly more
tempting or more desirable to want to
sleep with other people or be worried
like well I don't want to be stuck with
one person for the rest of my life
because you've had other experiences and
you know there's different levels of
quality yeah what if they're not as good
at sex as the last person that's
something that I got asked a lot well
you're waiting until you're married what
if he's not good at sex like I got asked
that all the time it's an interesting
question to pose I kind of look at it as
this seeking the next Thrill Is that
always the best thing for your life long
term for other people for Society for
yourself because it makes me think a lot
about porn and how it has progressed to
what it was from how long ago with
Playboy magazines to what it is now that
has like abuse you know all kinds of
horrible implications of what happens in
the porn industry and porn what porn
looks like and we've seen through
studies that people who look at porn
regularly especially have more and more
it's always like what's the next thing
okay I'm bored of this what's the next
like extreme thing I can get to and so
that's what it makes me think of with
the serial monogamy that it's like okay
what but this isn't I don't have the
butterflies anymore like maybe I'm
missing something maybe it says as
opposed to looking to that really to me
feels that deep deep bond that you have
when you're committed to one person and
it reminds you of Kim and Ami I don't
know if you know we talked about her and
how she just talks about how you know
when there's a an issue within a
relationship she's assuming a monogamous
relationship that you can't just like
learn the right sex moves or learn that
that's not what it is it's a deep deep
meaningful connection of like am I seen
am I supporting the others the other
supporting me selflessness like total
love for the other person where if your
relationship is struggling it's not that
you're not going to have good sex
together but if you have if you have um
an incredible relationship where you
grow evolve listen to each other's needs
also stay in yourself I'm not saying
drowning yourself to just support the
other person but it's the Oneness and
the unity that can make sex so
incredible and there isn't this like
well what else is out there because you
don't you don't you haven't started down
that road of the next thrill what are
your thoughts on that do you want to
share
yeah I think it all comes back to the
individual to be able to enhance your
own love and I think yeah searching
constantly externally for this happiness
and the sexual like almost living a
hedonistic reality or or yeah watching
porno and and trying to get this
satisfaction constantly from other
people and through porn and through all
these things that we're we're
conditioned to to think that these
things make us happy it always allows
you to revert back to your inner self
and I think that's what that's what
we've been very aware of is is if we are
aren't feeling happy within ourselves no
one else is going to give us happiness
or pleasure so I think we yeah we we
concentrate on working out how to get
this unconditional love for ourselves
and then I then you can almost feel it
boiling over and that's the point that's
when we get to the point where right
we're at a good point we're sharing it
with each other we've got an overlaid
and it's possible to share it with not
only other people but we do a lot of
animal rescue and we can like all that
love is just expressed in so many
different ways not just sexually but it
can be there's no right or wrong I don't
think yeah I felt like for me like the
one the one Tipping Point where I was
like all right I can really wrap my mind
around this it's just more from like I
guess a spiritual perspective you may
say of just people coming to our lives
for a reason and I felt like I didn't
want to I love Matt I wanted to start
creating our lives together I wanted to
you know commit to moving in together
and building a home together and
starting a family but also I didn't want
to block off any other connection or
possibility or friendship that may form
or whatever and it's not so much as
seeking it's more of like a I have a
total contentment and a bliss with where
I am in my life and also I do believe
that if I continue to stay open and you
know believe in opportunity and miracles
and things like that like the right
people will come into my lives at the
right time for a specific reason and I
just want to make sure I'm always able
to see them hear them be able to connect
whether it's romantic or just totally
platonic so for me that was kind of the
one thing we always say like you know
work towards happiness and I'll meet you
there like really fill your own cup and
we'll be there together so it's
I don't like the word expectation but
it's it's not me sitting here and saying
well you need to meet my sexual needs my
romantic my intellectual my emotional
you need to be my best friend you need
to be the greatest in bed you need to do
all this it's more how can I serve
myself enjoy having this amazing
connection and then if I do feel I need
to find something else elsewhere I'll
just make a point to you know do that
for myself whether it's like I said
sexual or just be great to have a new
friend or have a new guy friend or have
a new conversation with someone who's
interested in different things so
I don't even really know what the
original question was oh yeah it was
going in all different directions so so
I guess is your is your commitment to
each other is it lifelong or do you feel
like it's you know it is what it is if
we end up parting ways like what is the
purpose then of your commitment yeah
okay I'll say we we were married and in
our own sense of the word last year and
I love that you mentioned your wedding
vows and this sacred Testament to one
another we altered our wedding vows to
um yeah I think we I guess personally
I'll speak but
um of course we love fantasizing about
the idea of being together and you know
raising more children together and being
being able to travel and experience
lives together and also I guess I'm a
little bit more of the reality is I mean
I look at my parents marriage for
example and all my best friends marriage
parents marriages and divorce and
separation happens and that's a reality
and um of course it's not something that
we want to happen but I think we really
just say like every day is a choice to
choose to be together and yeah I I think
I guess we are kind of more in the flow
of like if we're meant to be together if
it feels amazing if it's feeling great
and of course there are hard times and
of course you know we experience that
but I would never want to bind you into
something that you know in 10 or 15
years from now I didn't feel yeah
rewarding for you or beneficial for you
and vice versa you know but I guess I
feel like if it's not rewarding or
beneficial and you're in this place
where it's like over
what would be the reason right it seems
to me like it's most likely most common
this isn't going to be like all
scenarios but one or both are not
willing to grow to the place where
you're flourishing right what would you
what could be the reason why you're like
I'm not into it is it because the lack
of butterflies you know what I'm saying
or is it because I'm just not liking the
way this person is or anymore I want to
go with this person this is why we see
so many people who divorce and then get
married and then divorce again because
well it's this person it's this right
but there's no one person that's just
gonna if you to think it's just gonna be
amazing always forever and if they're
not amazing I'm out because I think
there is something to say about the
sustability of knowing that you're going
to be there for me and I'm going to be
there for you when times are tough you
know because without that civility it's
like it's just I feel like see what you
feel like in 20 30 years and like I
don't know if that's gonna bring
happiness and I don't know but I think
for us it's not the dependence on
somebody else and it's not having that
person there I think it's just having
yourself there like I think that's the
work that we've been doing is just to be
just to realize that you are capable of
everything you don't need another person
and I think that's what I think that's
what is our relationships blossomed
under those
that sort of process isn't it it's like
the individual has everything it needs
it doesn't really need account it
doesn't really need to be held
accountable by someone else
but yeah there's like some sort of
I don't know what how he would say it
can I ask you you guys
um is divorce ever an option for you too
is this something you speak about no no
never an option never yeah so even if
you hypothetically found yourselves
unhappy in the relationship or both of
you well there has been times when we
were unhappy in the relationship but you
have a choice to how we move through
that and that's why I was saying it's
really a commitment between two people
to being willing to grow because when
one person is unwilling to Humble
themselves and see where they are where
there are faults within their own being
and figure out what they need to do to
create a more flourishing relationship
that's where that's where people get
stuck you know like oh well this person
was this way or let's say there's
someone in abusive relationship so this
whole never if I was being physically
abused or sexually abused or in any kind
of abuse that's of difference but to me
it comes down to being willing to grow
so the times when we have had really
intense struggles you don't just stay
there so you you have to grow and be
humble yourself to grow from it and then
we come out the other side and are more
deeper in love than ever before and it's
that love that the way that we treat
each other that creates that it's like
this this um understanding of the love
bank that every relationship every
person has a love bank and it's from
this book called his needs her needs
which is a little bit you know there's
things I don't love about it it's like
super conservative the way it's worded
in other in things but the concept is
super amazing and I'm sure a lot of
people everybody knows the love five
love languages but this is about 10
basic emotional needs and however
everybody has certain things that are
higher needs than others and they're
different and so with your love Bank
your partner or any relationship sister
mother friend they're either adding a
love coin to the bank or taking it out
through every interaction and every
experience whether it's a child
everything and if you take too many
coins out of the bank that love is
depleted and you don't feel that love
for that person anymore so the purpose
of the the the drive behind how are we
going to keep this relationship is
incred incredible and stable and loving
and deep and meaningful which actually
makes your sex better is adding love
coins to each other's bank so that's
that's kind of was that what was your
question yeah
yes letting you go yeah I mean even if
you weren't willing to grow it still
wouldn't be an option for me personally
because I have deeper convictions than
just my my own you know I have spiritual
convictions that even if you weren't
committed to the relationship I would
still be committed to you I would too
did I say that we weren't no no I'm not
putting words in your mouth I'm just
saying like but obviously if it's going
to be a healthy marriage like both sides
have to be committed to grow and if one
side's not then obviously it's going to
be very very difficult and unhappy and
it's gonna not gonna be good for the
kids either like one of my main concerns
was like open relationships and in
divorce more it's not good for the kids
but in monogamous relationships
obviously they end in divorce too
sometimes they stay together even when
they're struggling that's not good for
kids to see their parents going at each
other's throats either and one of the
reasons why oh sorry I keep going
one of the reason
people are unhappy is I feel like
there's a lot of selfishness in
relationships that can happen and one of
the things that's beautiful about you
guys are so conscious about this not
being selfish selfish and I think that's
beautiful
um but in relationships it can often be
and it could even have a non-monogamous
of what are you doing for me you're not
doing this you're not being this way
you're not instead of looking within
themselves be like where can I grow
where can I change and that that's what
makes a relationship more flourishing
more flourishing is humbling yourself
instead of pulling the finger at the
other it's what and what can I do to
shift the way that I am being what can I
do to grow and be better so that's what
has gotten us out of those hard times
and I'm sure there's plenty more I can
apply to any relationship any
relationship obviously that's something
we agree on 100 yeah and so I think
because we both kind of agree with that
right would you say you agree with the
selflessness absolutely yeah absolutely
that it really comes down to sex that is
it is it what is the purpose of sex
because this is the main the main
difference right because for you you're
saying it could be just a date
but it's a sexual chemistry right it's
intimate sexual chemistry or is it not
no I would say yeah I would argue it
doesn't come down to sex for us I think
it's more of just this knowing that
and it probably does answer the previous
question as well of like you're free to
always honor your needs and honor your
desires whether that be hey I really
feel I need to go on a backpacking trip
by myself or whatever you know I want to
learn a new language or I think I want
to live in India for a month or whatever
it may be so I think for us it's a it's
a bigger picture of
um yeah not so much just I we want to
have sex with other people or whatever
um but more just hey we want this to
work we want it and continue to enjoy
this long term hopefully if it feels
like the best thing to do and what do we
need to do as individuals to make sure
that we're both in a place where we're
able to show up as the best versions
most fulfilled happiest wholesome
versions of ourselves to be in an
enjoyable relationship with one another
yeah but like backpacking across the
world choosing to do that that doesn't
make it non-monogamous totally right so
the dog isn't it more actually about the
intimacy when you break it down of like
what exactly
yeah forming um like emotional or
romantic connections with other people
yeah definitely so do you feel like
going back to that next thrill thing
when you're going on other dates and
then you say oh let's try a threesome
let's do a four some of them uh the the
idea of like the rules and the
boundaries you got to make sure it's all
this stuff with the three thumbs up
because I was watching your video I
loved watching you guys talk and hearing
your perspective on that um it's it
sounds very transactional like it's just
it's it I feel like the word the idea
the words on paper of the beauty of
non-monagi it sounds nice but when it
actually comes down to actually doing it
it's very just to me it sounds like and
I want to understand you guys but it
sounds like transactional sex I'm okay
after you have sex do we decide if the
person leaves do they sleep in our bed
do they sleep another bed or do they
have to leave and so it's just the
experience of sex and so I guess the the
larger question of like is this good for
society is this good for kids like you
mentioned is this good for ourselves and
going back to the well I need to fulfill
my needs like trusting each other to
fulfill our needs and not having the
attachment it sounds really nice but is
I guess another philosophical question
it's like should we always act on our
impulses is that always good
I think for me every time we have an uh
experience outside of the I guess the
societal Norm
the next day there is a deliring process
and I think when we have connections
with other people the playfulness is is
probably the right word to use but then
we are in we are invoking that deeper
sense of unconditional love for
whoever's interacting but the next for
me anyway the next day is the construct
of what society's expectations of us as
humans as westerners dissipates which
which is the integration process is like
two or three days it takes like
sometimes we'll like communicate it
sometimes we need to spend time by
ourselves but when we do things that are
away from the society and we do things
on our own accord and create new things
and new sexual experiences there is a
dissolving of construct constructs that
have been placed on us to kind of
suppress our expression sexually so
those things that are put on us from
birth I guess slowly Edge away just
slowly come away and we're kind of a
little bit more Freer but then you do
have to be able to integrate that
process of of how you've experienced sex
with with other people can I ask you
you're 15 and 16 yeah when how old were
you when you were married 21 22 22 22.
you were 21 21 so would you say at that
age and obviously you know people get
married at all ages but you two were
fully confident making the choice that
this is it I'll never be with anyone
else I'll never
I'll never crave a sexual War whatever
explorative I'll never want to be
curious about exploring sex with a woman
in or with a male or anything like that
you both were confident in making that
choice at 21 and 22. I was extremely
confident and
very confident and you're the only
person I want to spend the rest of my
life with that was definitely yeah
couldn't wait just so excited to have
that commitment of it's you and me
there's nobody else that I want right to
be with that's beautiful but maybe you
want to expand more I mean I had a
different set of beliefs then I mean I
called myself Christian but I wasn't
wasn't a practicing Christian but I kind
of just had this belief like oh yeah
this is what I do and part of that's my
upbringing like I grew up in a Christian
home I had parents that had been married
for 40 plus years I only know successful
marriages like most my friends uh
parents had good good marriages released
were together so that was my view of
marriage in the world I knew of divorces
like a lot of my aunts and uncles had
been divorced but
so that was just that's that's how we
were supposed to do it like why would
you do it any other way it wasn't
necessarily
I don't know how much of it was like a
personal conviction I just felt like
that's what I do of course I commit to
you I love you I would I want to be with
anybody else I don't know if I fully
wrap my head around it I mean uh but as
we've been married it's just been more
solidified it's like obviously I'm gonna
do this and I'm even more confident
probably than I was then because it's
hard to fully know it 21 or 22. right
what it's going to feel like in 10 years
or where you're going to be at we're
complete we're very different people
than we were when we got married like
even when we just met we were completely
different people then when we just met
that's why I think so many young people
don't end up staying together because
you're changing your brain is not fully
developed you and most people grow apart
from each other but we happen to grow I
don't know if it happened or if it
wasn't you know what's the reason behind
it but we grew together where I took on
more of his admirable qualities and he
took on more of my admirable qualities
and we were able to shed away the things
that were not as as admirable quality
qualities that were our best selves and
so we evolved and grew together but it's
it's amazing how different we are at 15
and 16. I mean everybody is completely
different right at that point so I mean
I think back to those days when we were
super young and I am so glad that I was
not having sex at 16 17 18 19. I was not
emotionally
um ready for that and once we got
married it was like yeah now we got the
rest of our lives to explore and learn
and grow and our sex life at you know
the first times being together versus
now is a million times better like I
can't even when you look back to like
our first time just you know kids just
figuring it out but but the difference
is that there was just a complete Safety
and Security of knowing like knowing the
person because I think when you don't
know someone I mean I don't have
personal experience with it but just
from friends who have had sex with
people that they don't really know that
there's a lot more insecurity a lot more
just lack of safety with not knowing
this person something that's so intimate
and to me like life soul type bonding
and having that complete love for each
other that I mean you guys have love for
each other so that's not like of course
not trying to compare that but that I
just felt completely safe and seen with
that person so we grew together with
that and I mean our sex life has evolved
to be so much better than it was even
when we first got married and that's so
beautiful that it isn't just like a oh
are you good at sex or are you not is
that we both learned how to be how to
please each other and how to make it a
selfless like life altering like bed
shaking experience you know whereas a
lot of times you hear it's just like
portrayed in the media that oh if you're
married for such a long time then sex is
going to be blood like you you better go
see other people and my personal our
personal experience is everyone we know
who has been married monogamous and
chose to open the relationship that it
was like a last resort thing like oh
maybe this is what we need and then it
just fell apart and for the kids was not
obviously it's not something good for
kids it's something that we see in all
kinds of studies that children who grow
up in the single income or single home
versus two parents
um dramatic differences in their
childhood and the outcomes of their life
you know being The Graduate in high
school less likely to go to prison all
kinds of different things so yeah that's
my thoughts what do you think yeah I
think they're great thanks for sharing I
love you guys by the way I love
you I think it's so fascinating and
interesting to hear come to hear us both
with a completely different ideas but
still there's so much love involved in
your choices you know it's clear thank
you for sharing more of your experience
being married so young and respectfully
I think I struggle to maybe not agree
but I struggle to understand how one
could make such a long lasting decision
at such a young age that you know like
even I have you know I see on social
media now more and more people getting
married 19 20 18 21 or whatever and I
mean I know when I met Matt I was 24 and
there was no way I was willing to give
anyone a a solid answer of I only want
to do this for the rest of my life just
because there was so much I hadn't yet
experienced that I was still curious
about so yeah what are your thoughts on
on that or well I think a lot of it has
to do with culture and then your own
experiences like I mentioned like my
view of marriage was different than
yours great you know Mom and Dad
situation and then culture obviously
like our grandparents it was very very
common to get married right after high
school right I think my mom said that
like half of her friends after they
graduated high school got married right
and the success rate of those marriages
they stayed married longer I don't know
if their relationships were necessarily
better but the divorce rates have only
gone up as we've delayed marriage right
I don't necessarily have an answer for
why I just think a lot of that is
cultural and then your experiences
growing up as divorces become more and
more normal younger people are seeing
that I mean like huh because the average
age of getting married now even though
there are people that get married young
like you see people get married young
right the average age of getting married
is much higher than it was in the
previous generation or even the previous
generation
so I feel like if anything it's moving
towards people losing trust in the
system because they're seeing so many
people are growing up in broken homes
right and so it's like why would I want
to do that so I get why what people
would want to explore but for us
I just it seemed like a no-brainer both
of us it's really interesting we were
talking about this last night how both
of us grew up in a household where both
of our parents are still together and
both of your parents did not say that
yeah it's such an interesting absolutely
our experiences totally shape how we
view the world totally and it seems to
me like we are more likely now we're
getting more aware of how to grow and
evolve as a person you know it might
have been through our grandparents
generation of like just stay together
and it doesn't matter what the what the
outcome or how the marriage is you just
don't get divorced because that's like a
shame in society right but now it seems
like we're a lot more understanding of
like the mind-body connection of your
experiences and how they shape your
traumas and how you view the world and
being able to heal from those traumas
there's a lot of different more
modalities now on how to heal from your
traumas and tap into your emotions I
feel like from what it was a couple
Generations ago but that's just my what
I'm looking at I don't know I don't know
what you think about that it relates
back to that kind of the monogamy
Continuum that I talked about it's like
it's perfect for YouTube because you
both have the same values the same ideas
of monogamy excuse me in Partnership and
yeah I think for a lot of people in
order to find a partner that makes you
feel like your needs are being met
you're fulfilled and you're in this
happy relationship they need to be in a
very similar space than you do you know
and I argue as I'm a little bit younger
than you know than you guys and I have
probably a bit more of a progressive
friend group now because of the
lifestyle I live but I just see so many
people continue to explore and then they
learn totally new things about
themselves or oh my God I can't believe
it but I'm actually interested in women
now I think or whatever so
um yeah I don't know I guess I just
believe that the more room for
experimentation and exploration is maybe
better results in like self awareness
and more yeah like knowledge and
confidence in who you are and what you
want and I think a lot of people don't
realize like in order to have that
incredible partnership where both people
are in the same terms you really do need
to find someone who's on the same place
in that Spectrum as you and I wasn't
really able to identify where I was on
that Spectrum at the time that I met
Matt so I think we had there was room
for discussion and room for flexibility
in the future of hey if you decide you
want something totally different than I
do you don't need to decide right now
we're just gonna continue to feel into
this and you know see see what develops
and you know even personally like I knew
when I met Matt I'd never been with a
woman before I thought maybe one day I
want to experiment or explore with that
I don't know and you know I've vocalized
that to him and he was like cool maybe I
want to have you know group experiences
in the future or whatever so we kind of
just left room open for those
circumstances and now I guess I'm
probably biased but I struggle to you
know believe about an 18 year old or a
21 year old or a 24 year old can say Yep
this is exactly what I want for the next
60 years of my life even though it's
probably a reality for many people it's
just a personal
well I think it's definitely like you
said having the same beliefs like
similar belief system about what is the
purpose of our relationship and also the
fact that we had been together for so
long was one reason why we felt so
confident it wasn't but then again
there's a lot of people who get married
after one year and they also feel
confident in the moment but maybe later
they're like oh shoot I didn't know this
about this person right right but it's
the it's what what is the goal basically
it comes down to it's the growing
together being committed to each other
and like you said like for us raising
healthy children yeah I guess basically
that's what it comes down to yeah well
children that's a good thing to bring up
too because like obviously children are
very important but like our relationship
has to be the most important in order to
have in order to be able to stay
together for our kids right and be good
parents our relationship has to be good
right so one advice that I would give to
couples that are having children is like
make sure you focus on your relationship
with your spouse more than your kids
if your kids come first
you're gonna you're gonna struggle those
kids are really hard and and they see it
they feel it when you're not doing well
so that's one reason why you guys might
have this view of like look if it's not
that they got divorced you know there's
there are people who say that that they
felt better that their parents got
divorced I definitely feel that way I
don't know about and I'm sure you do as
well yeah yeah but yeah I mean I was
really young but even just seeing the
relationship they had after the divorce
I was thinking thank God I didn't live
in that household with those people for
much longer than I did together in that
and that way but similar to you I grew
up in like a really um I wouldn't say
strict but a very Catholic religious
home and
um divorce was not an option for my
parents as well and even when my parents
went to the church the church didn't
allow it and they had to go to marital
therapy with the priest before it was
even something that was an option for
them and yeah it was a it was a big a
big decision for them and I do feel
grateful that it you know it did result
in the way it did and I believe they're
both happier outside of the marriage and
although I can't speak for children that
grew up in homes with two parents there
I do have a beautiful relationship with
both my parents so I'm so lucky that
that's the case and you grew up Matt's
parents were divorced later in life at
18 so he had a really different
experience than I did yeah yeah my
parents I guess weren't compatible from
the start I would say they're just two
different people
wanting two different things from life
but I guess they try to make it work and
they got to the point where it wasn't
gonna work and yeah they divorced but I
don't know
I guess just going back to that question
of like what is the purpose of sex I
feel like we kind of keep going around
it we're kind of answering but what what
do you think the purpose of it is
I think it's still
consciousness
only discovering that I guess that maybe
when I was 47 it's just something
clicked I think it was between us no I
know it's between us
um this feeling of like something
expanded within me and it brought us
both in it brought me closer to Amelia
and I hadn't experienced that and I I
guess I've had a lot of sex but that one
point was like it was something
transformative it was like the Mind
something went beyond my physical body
and I as I was lying there and I
couldn't move for maybe 30 minutes
that's the day we had the earthquake
remember
there's an earthquake like five minutes
after that we like hurry up when we're
at badang okay you're like what's this
life-changing sex I don't remember I do
remember the sex but I don't want it but
it was for me it probably wasn't I think
it was an individual thing for me it was
like this thing that exploded with you
maybe I've had it I've had it since but
that was the first time I'd ever
experienced this kind of Awakening it
was just like Beyond just pleasure it
was like this expansion of something
within me which is like which they say
could be could leaning activation or or
maybe it was our breathing technique and
it was DMT
exposed or whatever who knows but yeah I
think that was that was probably off the
top of my head that experience of sex
that time was yeah was another level
that I'd never experienced before thank
you so then how is that not good enough
saying with just her what is it that
makes you need more and somebody else
and I think Andrew you guys would be
good to talk together about that that
idea of you know when you see another
woman that's attractive like what is the
point where what are your philosophies
on that but you go ahead first I think
as it goes beyond sex there's something
when you meet somebody else whether
they're like if we go on a date and
majority of the time it's we're just
meeting up and having a conversation and
then we'll either go our separate ways
or have another date of very rarely will
constantly be an experience of something
sexual but
there is something there is some sort of
chemistry when you meet someone new or
different that there's this familiar
there's this familiarity with within
that connection and then the
intellectual connection comes in and
there's a little bit of an emotional and
then I feel like there is a sp there is
something spiritual that we can have
with more than one person that we can
connect and then once you've grasped
those connections then the sex is almost
just on top of that you've already
established something spiritual between
this person maybe they've come to teach
you something about yourself that your
part current partner can't and I think
we've both experienced just meeting
different people and going I never
thought of life that way I'm more aware
of this now so like I think people are
drawn to us to kind of broaden our
peripheral on awareness and awareness of
like our emotions and you know different
parts of ourselves that we've been
unaware of or we haven't reaffirmed um
and then sex is I think once you've
established that within the intellectual
and the spiritual and the emotional
connection with somebody then the sexual
sex is usually just the icing and the
sex is usually good if those other
connections are I guess jointly yeah
just yeah I don't know the word what do
you say I'm really interested
reciprocated reciprocated yeah
yeah
by Dr Wednesday Martin called untrue
which is incredible I recommend it to
anyone who messages me or is interested
in learning more about um
non-monogamy but she has like been
researching for years and it's a wide
array of things that you know she speaks
about in the book from
we share 98.7 percent of our genetic
material with bonobo monkeys who are
notoriously you know non-monogamous in
their natural environment excuse me and
women
you know there's a lot of I don't say
proof but there's a lot of research
coming out that um what's the word
looking for incurred no
oh my gosh illuminates or whatever the
fact that women might be might benefit
more from multi you know sexual multiple
sexual partners from women for example
the average woman it takes 20 minutes
for the average woman to have an orgasm
20 minutes yes and then for a man it
takes 2.5 to 5 minutes on average for a
man to come to ejaculation so if a
woman's taking 20 minutes and a man's
taking on average 2.5 to 5 minutes what
happens there what happens when it's
been two and a half three minutes in the
man's already orgasm and he has a long
refractory period it's called when he's
able to perform sexually again and I
think it's on average 12 to 24 hours for
most men before they can have sex again
so what happens there for the woman who
hasn't yet reached Climax and is maybe
laying in bed for another 18 or 17
minutes without you know
um without reaching climax and
um yeah just from like the clitoris
alone like our biology and how the
clitoris is a huge gland as large as
men's you know
um genitalia on their glands and the
nerve endings and the clitoris alone and
just that men's spermicide immense sperm
excuse me contains spermicide at the
um final remnants of their ejaculation
it can contains spermicide that
potentially would have been used to kill
off any other sperm from another man
that might have been in the woman's body
previously to having sex so I think
um the more research I'm doing about
female biology and just some of these
studies that are coming out I do believe
that maybe
um some or most women are meant to have
benefit from the pleasure of having
multiple sexual partners because we're
able to just experience more pleasure
and what I talked about with limerence
in the sex drive you know depleting for
me it's just been more of like all right
I can just read this research and I can
also know monogamy and what it's like
but I do have sexual desires and I do
meet someone else or come across another
man or have form of friendship and I do
feel that Sexual Energy and that sexual
chemistry building so for me it's just a
choice of do I want to pursue it and
follow it or do I not want to and I
guess I've chosen the path of wanting to
pursue it and follow it in my own way
so I don't feel that sex is
transactional I can understand totally
how you may think that
um but I don't know it almost feels like
it's hard to comment because everyone's
sex is so different we can't pretend to
know what other people's sex and their
connection is like we know what ours is
like and no one else knows what ours is
like and um for us we've just found that
exploring sexuality in these different
ways personally and together has led to
what we feel is a healthier and more
exciting sex life you know for us
because we do have the permission and
the space to explore more and explore
together
um which you know a lot of people in
monogamy aren't don't choose to do
so
I did not answer the question well I
just want to respond to what you said
about
um about this research coming out that
you're feeling like maybe women would
benefit from multiple
um relationships I would actually kind
of argue the opposite and when it comes
to
um a man taking 2.5 minutes what I would
argue is that men need to last longer
and that's something this this idea that
oh man yeah 2.5 minutes just get it in
totally that's not gonna pleasure the
woman because women like you said take
longer it's like the whole men are a
microwave women are a stove and that
takes longer
um and a deep meaningful sex would be to
spend your time warming up loving on
that person in all the ways and Men
working on lasting longer so I mean our
sex is definitely not 2.5 minutes I
would you know the Kim and Nami way is
like three hours sex day and Men it is
on you to step up and last longer right
so what you're proposing this idea that
men only lasts 2.5 minutes so what do
you do when you're laying there for 72
or more minutes are you suggesting that
oh just let another guy come in insert
in that to me is not the answer the
answer is men work on lasting longer to
please your woman and you guys you
please each other that way for longer
more intimate deeper sex and I think the
idea of women needing or maybe being
designed to have more Partners
um I would focus more on childbearing
and how it is more likely that the
design of us having a baby to take care
of shows us that we need one partner to
stick with us through thick and through
thin to protect and and help and raise
and be that strong masculine like I'm
with you to protect you in all things
um that shows us that we need that one
person because if you have multiple
you're more likely for STDs and more
likely to have unplanned pregnancies
that's just the reality if you're not
having sex in a way until you're married
and you're only with that one person
there's no way that you're going to have
sex with someone that you weren't
planning that you aren't willing to have
a baby with or to get pregnant
um so there's that I feel like to me the
biology is really clear that we are we
are if you're going to look at biology
right that we are actually designed to
meet one man stay with me because I
might have a baby if I get pregnant
you're there to protect me and help me
and be there with me
um and if you're saying we'll save sex
and all that none of that is part of
nature you know the condoms and to birth
control is that that completely disrupts
nature so right really talking about
nature right the nature would be just
having sex with no protection and so
that would be clearly one person because
if you're pregnant with a baby that's
not the man's baby right and they're
like I'm gonna go with someone else who
doesn't have another baby because and I
don't take care of that baby do you know
what I'm saying so that's why to me it
feels really clear that specifically
women are right we need one person right
but to argue that if I may yeah don't go
back some of the some of the researches
you know these bonobos specifically is
what I'm learning most about so if you
care to relate at all or if that's your
thing or not but it's showing quite the
opposite of the more male monkeys that
female monkeys are having sex with the
more protection the longer the child's
more likely to live because there are
more men who think oh it might be my
baby so I should stick around to be able
to provide food support protection
there's actually studies coming out that
a male monkey will never kill ever no
matter what type of aggression or acts
of violence they're in or tribal
fighting or whatever it may be a male
monkey will never kill The Offspring of
a monkey that he's had sex with before
because there's some slight chance that
it could be his own offspring so in the
in the jungle in the wild you know it
talks a lot about protection food
security nourishment you know for both
the mother and the child so it's
interesting to consider both yeah but I
do think that animal studies are no
matter how close our DNA are is not
comparison to human studies we live in
totally because we are different and
even though there's close you know DNA
it's still drastic like we have so much
DNA so like you know monkeys lick their
own butts too yeah I'm gonna do that you
know so just that aspect of a human
study of what that's like and what we
see at Society at large when uh with a
woman having a baby that's not right
their own and what the implications are
of that and you could argue culture
totally totally but um I think like a
human study would be a lot more valid
yeah yeah one of my questions or in the
beginning we were saying my concerns
what am I it's more of a question and a
concern but like multiple partners
there's more of a chance for unplanned
pregnancies multiple partners there's
more of a chance for STDs and for
society as a whole you think society
would be better off I I personally think
like if everyone just had one sexual
partner obviously we wouldn't have the
need probably for to discuss even
abortions there would rarely ever be
them because every pregnancy would be
within the construct of a marriage or
one partner there wouldn't be STDs there
wouldn't have been all these oh the AIDS
outbreak that caused so many deaths I
don't know if that was specifically
related to that but it going it kind of
goes against our biology when we're
start we're creating new STDs or having
all these unplanned pregnancies whereas
if you don't have multiple Partners
that's not a risk the risk is literally
zero and the only way you can really
prevent pregnancy I mean there's other
ways the Surefire way to prevent
pregnancy is obviously not have sex and
then the next is put on a condom or take
a medication which is not natural like
you can if we're going back if we're
going if we're having the discussion
about biology and he's right that the
amount the percentage of abortions with
a woman who has a secure partner and is
married it's a lot smaller most of them
to my understanding over 80 of abortions
are non-married
relationships yeah of course yeah yeah
it gets into a whole new topic right yes
I think that's that's my concern you
have what are your thoughts on that how
do you prevent or protect against
unplanned pregnancies and STDs when
you're with multiple people
I guess
when I we sort of make up our own roles
so
well I think I'll share first like
if I may like infidelity happens you
know like it's for us it's not a
question of how can we or in our it's
not a question of how you know how can
we make monogamy perfect or whatever
it's like the reality is infidelity
always happens it has since the dawn of
time so whether you if every single
person in the world was in a monogamous
partnership there's still always going
to be extramarital sex or extramarital
partnership or whatever so for us and
we're like all right well we know that's
not a possibility to achieve so if we do
feel we have different desires and want
to explore life a different way what's
not a possibility to achieve to have a
monogamous relationship where you don't
cheat on each other well for all people
to have a monogamous story yeah yeah
obviously well but I think it should be
clear that we're not advocating for that
type of marriage right you know that
we're we're advocating for a radically
different kind of marriage right that
doesn't happen right right but go ahead
but I guess we're speaking on the
majority of monogamous relationships in
our current Society probably are not
anywhere nearly as beneficial and and
connected and committed and healthy as
yours as yours is so
um yeah there's a lot of statistics and
a lot of facts and I obviously don't
know all of them perfectly but you know
the reality is people who are
non-monogamous relationships are no more
likely to get STDs or um
yeah STDs than people who are single
living out you know just single life or
you know not in a committed monogamous
partnership but just sleeping with other
people yeah I mean I imagine that would
be the same stuff
you have more Partners you have a higher
risk of Contracting than this yeah you
have less Partners you have a lower risk
yeah you have more sex you're more
likely to have an unplanned pregnancy if
you have less sex I mean well with
different people yeah that's with
anybody yeah I'm just generally speaking
Yeah
yeah
we're just I guess
the question we're just extra you know
okay we're careful and use protection
like we would like I would have when I
before I was dating Matt or whatever and
um yeah we everyone has their own
methods of protection and we have ours
and
um yeah like I said it's always about
consideration for the other person you
know as much as it is for ourselves so
um we talk about that in depth of you
know this is why we use protection and
we if we if there was a slip up or an
incident or something like that you know
it's always clearly communicated or and
we would never want to risk giving
something to our partner or anything
like that so yeah of course it is a
reality of non-monogamy it hasn't
affected us personally
[Music]
um
yeah well I think it it boils down to
kind of like what uh we're advocating
for both of us but I'm going to speak
only to myself so lots of the types of
episodes I'm having on my podcast are
about growth mindset how to be the best
you know your relationship and parenting
so I would argue that our society at
large is really suffering because of you
know like the high rates of unhappiness
and divorce and infidelity and all these
things but is it just because oh this
isn't our biology we're actually
supposed to be non-monogamous and in an
ideal world it would be like what you
guys are doing or is it that in an Ideal
World we would actually be like having a
Victor mindset not a victim mindset and
having a much higher expectation for
ourselves and our ability to grow and be
the best version of ourselves the best
parents we can be the best spouse we can
be if we were all living like that how
much better of a world that would be and
how much better that would be for
children growing in a stable home where
their parents are madly in love with
each other and
serve each other and sacrifice in a way
that's obviously supporting yourself but
also helping others and seeing that
modeled to them of going out into the
world like that I imagine that would be
a much different world but that's not
the world we're seeing because there's
so much Brokenness in relationships so
is it because we're not designed to be
in a relationship like that or is it
because we're doing something wrong
that's creating infidelity and creating
cheating and dishonesty and all that
stuff so yeah
I think the society is the problem
because the statistics in Australia
alone I think it's 2 500 men age between
18 and 45 commit suicide every year so
something's wrong with the society
but I think as we broaden our awareness
of different ways to express love and to
express ourselves people don't feel so
suppressed within adopting things from
the society same as web if we're cooking
a meal at home and it's and we've like
years maybe vegan meats or something and
someone that's non-vegan comes in and
goes I can't believe you guys have
cooked this way like there is an
alternative so I think if we can get
across that point that you can be
monogamous you can be monogamous you can
be anything that you wanna you can
express yourself in any means possible
and then I think once we allow that and
we become more receptive and accepting
of other people then those statistics
should especially for men I think men
they've got to adhere to being fathers
they've got all these titles and
attachments that they have to adhere to
and some men feel those expectations are
too much they just can't
fulfill these Society expectations so
they end their lives and yeah it's just
something that has to change it's just
but I think that conversations like this
podcasts like this to broaden our
awareness that there's many ways that we
can relate ourselves to other people and
to our families and and especially for
like our children as well I think with
my kids I'm always like you can be
whatever you want you don't put yourself
in these boxes but I've said that from
when they're like a very early age you
can express yourself in any form you
want so there's always that
understanding that you don't have to
conform to these constructs or place
yourself in these boxes because I think
when we do we have very little room to
move well I think just to answer that
question or that idea of like freedom
and sexual Freedom it makes me think of
the sexual Revolution how you know when
that started happening you know decades
ago we have seen now through studies and
very clearly that we're not happier
we're not actually more sexually free
we're not the sexual Freedom didn't
actually make us happier and this idea
of oh yeah sleep with whoever and you
don't need to wait till you're married
and because that was a much more common
um value a while ago than it is now now
if you wait till you're married to have
sex it's like almost unheard of and it's
looked at it as like what even when we
were dating he was made fun of by his
friends it was still even back then
considered so just imagine how it was
decades ago and what it has become now
is just we don't value that sacredness
of the bond of a commit committed
relationship being willing to grow and
it hasn't made us happier we have higher
rates of depression we have more like a
single woman who has a baby with an
unplanned pregnancy has a higher rates
of poverty which isn't as good for the
baby and for the child growing up less
likely to graduate high school and like
anyone listening with that experience of
course like you are amazing and
everything you're doing this is not to
put down like your experience it's just
showing the realities of like is this
actually good for us to just sleep with
whoever and from what I'm seeing it's
clear that it's not but obviously you
guys are saying something different you
have anything to say Well it goes back
to what the question of like what is sex
like what is the purpose of it what is
and
I mean for me it's I mean pleasure is
obviously part of it but it's for
procreation I mean that's biology that's
what sex is for and then I I believe it
was created for the connection between
the person you're having it with and
that deeper connection they can only
share with a person you have sex with
like there's just a different level of
connection once you have sex with that
person that's why it was ultimately
created in your in our opinion and yeah
and that's what I believe yeah and also
just the it's the after sex too like
with the whole oh with an extra partner
we may be sending them off or I'm gonna
leave I'm not gonna stay in the bed part
of that Bond I mean from my experiences
our experiences is the after too that
connection after and it enriches our
relationship as opposed to okay goodbye
I'm gonna go back to this relationship
but I think for you guys at C I don't
want to put words in your mouth that
seems like the sex is more that's that
sexual experience enhanced my life now
I'm going to go back to my partner
whereas for us our sexual experience
enhanced our relationship but I have a
question yeah can I ask and very clearly
not to connect having sex and children
at all separate subjects but when you
had your first son and you were pregnant
with your second baby did you fear that
you wouldn't be able to love your second
baby as much as you had first loved your
first son Elvis I didn't have that fear
but I know that that is a fear some
people have and then once they have
their second baby they realize that at
least from everyone I've spoken to it's
not that you have this infinite amount
of love and this might be where you're
going but yeah find out about love where
you go oh they've already taken up all
the space now and I have a new baby like
there's no more room right but it just
expands your love so I'm guessing that's
where you're going yeah I believe that's
possible like I love you with my whole
heart and I love our lives together and
also I believe that I love friends so
much and I you know family and there's I
believe that it's possible to have a
deep deep intimate connection and love
and sexual connection and emotional
connection with more with more than one
person and maybe it's not for everyone
and maybe everyone's hearts and souls
are different but I believe for me it's
a possibility that there is room for
expansion there and I can still achieve
the same level of depth and connection
with you and also know that it's a
possibility that maybe one day I'll
experience it with someone else too so
the connection thing it just like I
never really realized I could have a
connection with other guys like in the
way that I do now like my friends
growing up it was more of just like you
hang out you have a good time together
right I didn't realize that I could have
deeper connections with people that
weren't my wife or even people with the
same sex like that was just like a block
I had I don't know a reason why but I
don't need sex to have obviously a
connection and I don't think you're
necessarily saying that but it helped
helped open me up to so many different
things by being able to connect with
people on a on a deeper level and
relationships and I think I kind of
learned that from being with her and
having to learn how to love someone more
than myself even obviously having
children and then then realizing that I
can have connections with other people
and it would greatly improve my life and
help me see new things and I didn't I
never really thought about needing sex
for that but yeah and having children is
like that too and you know with your
committed partner and having children it
teaches you how to love others more than
yourself right but to me it seems like
having
choosing this like oh this is what I
want this is what I need without for us
it seems like realizing the
repercussions potential repercussions
the greater risk of repercussions then
it's more like a this is what satisfies
me in the moment but is satisfying every
urge is our impulse is actually good for
us good for society good for our
children and to us it comes at the end
of the day that it doesn't seem like it
does but for you guys it seems like it
would and so it feels like kind of where
we would end up leaving off but do you
have any
no no all I was going to say is yeah I
think for me personally I feel sex is an
expression of something of my of like
some innate deep love that I need to
express
and I would do that not only with Amelia
but I would try and express this
deepness of love to anyone that I meet
whether it's um sexual or non-sexual I
would hope that I that just myself would
be able to somehow Express that sort of
love for that deepness
but yeah
I have one question unless you have
something else maybe just kind of to end
it does sure I know just from speaking
from my friends not my own experience
but friends who have had sex with people
that they are close with that they often
feel a sense of emptiness afterwards
that it wasn't actually meaningful and
it feels empty do you ever feel that way
with a partner that you have where it
felt like an empty
um
transaction that wasn't I know I don't
want to use a transaction because you
don't feel that way so let me take that
back but an empty experience that wasn't
as fulfilling as maybe you thought it
would be yeah and maybe this is like a
more of a conversation of should we have
sex before marriage or should we have
sex with multiple people because it's
obviously like such different
circumstances but before being with Matt
definitely I had sexual experiences that
left me feeling feeling icky after or
feeling like it wasn't a equal exchange
of energy and connection but no I'd
argue that since um being together and
it's almost like we I don't want to say
we value sex more but we're extra
um intentional and extra deliberate and
extra compassionate and extra
considerate and we don't want to yeah
just simply because we don't need sex
because we have it with each other we
don't need so it's like it's almost like
an extra
I don't know it's like an extra topping
or something so if we're gonna do it
outside of the relationship we want to
make sure it's done really well with
with integrity and empathy and
compassion and you mentioned you know
after a group sex experiencing like that
someone goes home or that's not our
style at all like we believe it is a
spiritual experience and connection and
we want to make sure everyone's needs
are feeling are being met and everyone's
comfortable with the situation and it's
common for us to follow up with people
after or have them over for a dinner and
you know the next night or whatever and
create that space for how are you guys
feeling are you feeling awkward or are
you feeling embarrassed or did anything
come up that you didn't feel good about
and just feeling that all emotions are
valid and we would rather explore all of
them than not I guess explore all of
them so yeah and I think that if you're
having emptiness like sex that's
meaningless then you're attracting that
but that's you attracting like
attracting luck so if we're attracting
people that we're having emptiness
meaningless sex with we've got to take a
deeper look at ourselves uh who and I
think that's the perfect gauge I think
when we go on dates who we attract to us
gives us a gay like a self-reflective
gauge on this person's amazing and look
who I've attracted into my life they're
loving and caring and they're so deep
and and I think then it's like this
gauge whereas if you're meeting someone
they're like let's just get drunk over
you know let's just have sex it's like
is that me so I think it's a it's kind
of like a gauge isn't it you can use
connection as a as such a
self-reflective gauge like nothing else
like there's nothing else that can give
you such and we and and using each other
as these so our perfected gauges as well
yeah so I have one more question
actually
um what is your plan or your thoughts on
how it is quite common then for and even
in a monogamous relationship where they
cheat and there's infidelity quite most
of the time it's because they're not
getting something fulfilled in their
marriage so they seek outside uh sexual
experiences and then there's the
butterflies and the chemistry and you
don't have all the baggage of the I know
exactly oh I hate the way this person
does this and this and this and this
person isn't like that but really you
just don't know the person every person
has their flaws that you end up starting
to fall in love with somebody else and
you fall essentially out of love of that
or you have already fallen out of love
with that person instead of working on
that relationship to fall back in love
and to stay in unconditional love
because do you ever what are your
thoughts on that like if you start
dating someone you have sex with them
and you feel all the butterfly feelings
that maybe 15 years down the road 10
years on the road you don't have with
each other anymore because of just the
natural changes that happen within a
relationship the long you know know each
other and that's in with Sisterhood and
family you know the person like the back
of your hands so it's a lot more relaxed
it's not as putting your best foot
forward you're more likely to be your
less best version of yourself right so
how common it is to go to that person
and think oh well this is actually the
person for me like we you know we know
scenarios like that where this is not
actually the person for me right but
really over time that person isn't you
don't feel that same you end up feeling
the same thing you felt with the first
person because over time if you don't
work on yourself and you're just looking
at like the oh you're this way
you're not providing the needs that I
want anymore you're no longer what I
need then it ends up going from person
to person and if you bring kids into
that relationship that's where it ends
up making it that's why there's a higher
likelihood of if you open the
relationship to have a higher divorce
rate which isn't good for kids in
general so I'd also question those
statistics
um in honesty simply because most
non-monogous people they're less likely
to be married and also I feel like just
being who we are in the mindset we have
in the perspective on life what really
is marriage to non-monogamous people
it's probably very different so I kind
of question you know most monogamous
marriages end in in divorce or for us
it's like we say we were married but we
weren't really legally married so where
do we fall on that yeah this is focusing
on like marriages who chose to open up
to a relationship or they were married
so it just takes into account marriages
at some point open the relationship okay
I think as well lost is when we meet
someone new and it's like that new
feeling it's just lost I mean we all
have love in the way that we express it
but
being drawn to someone with that new
energy and that lust you can you can
understand it and you can understand
like unconditional love very different
and we've been able to communicate that
like totally struggles with last it's
like I want to spend so much time with
this other person and so it's like yeah
we can evaluate whether it's lust or
whether it's like a really deep
connection with
pursuing right and like what you said we
know 15 years down the line we know each
other like the back of our hand we know
how we use the toilet and whatever like
yeah
it's not the same or just they have this
tone with me all the time and right like
this person doesn't have that tone right
without remembering that like you guys
didn't have that tone in the beginning
of your relationship totally you know
yeah I think it's just a bit more of
awareness of okay I can meet a new guy
out next weekend but and he feels he
feels amazing and he seems incredible
but I don't know what he's been like for
the last five years like I don't know
what his life's look like I don't know
how he's chose to act in challenging
times or shut up for family or friends
and so I think it's very similar to how
you guys feel in times of maybe
turbulence or trouble within the
marriages I'm I'm going to come back to
you more than likely because I love you
and I know that we're working towards a
shared life together and
um and then and also at the same time is
our beliefs are more things happen for a
reason and as they're meant to and for
us I think Unconditional Love Is There
Are No Boundaries or no rules or
um
guidelines well there of course there
are guidelines but no no um you're never
allowed to do this ever and so that is a
reality that we talk about of what if
you meet someone new in 10 years or 15
or 30 years and I would like to sit here
and think from this position that I love
you so much that no matter what is best
for you whether it's in a partnership
with me or someone else I would be able
to open my heart and and give you the
love and the support you need to be able
to do what's best for him and his life
and I'm sure your views are very
different yeah because it comes back to
like children too you know yeah but also
then I go back to my parents that like
they made those sacred vows in the
Catholic Church of until death do us
part and then it was probably because of
us my sisters and I that they decided
the Pelt is going to do for our family
is to end this marriage so I know we
can't speak to like their personal
experience just not like the broader
understanding of what divorce gen like
often generally does to kids right yeah
yeah definitely yeah so
number one reason people get married is
just differences it's not even normal
you mean get divorced yeah get divorced
they grew apart at least that's what
people put on their divorce application
or whatever the forms they have to fill
out uh which is really sad really it's
like if both people are working on
themselves that will never happen
obviously there's infidelity and things
like that well that happened that's a
that's a like a result of that's not
working on each other's selves together
so I mean what's good for society what's
good for the next generation of people
I'm even going into a relationship being
on the same page and being in a whether
whether it's an open relationship or a
committed monogamous relationship like
relate families aren't going to be
better Society is not going to be better
unless both people in a relationship are
have the same growth mindset like you
had mentioned want to become better
um
but at the same time you brought up
everything happens for a reason but
sometimes we put ourselves into
situations that cause those things to
happen like okay so we had an unplanned
pregnancy well it happens for a reason
well you chose to have sex with someone
and then it resulted in an unplanned
pregnancy so there's obviously like
certain things do happen for a reason I
believe things everything happens for a
reason but sometimes it's because we put
ourselves in those situations so what I
my what I would teach my kids is don't
put yourself in situations that are
going to increase your chances of having
an outcome that you don't want so if you
don't want to have unplanned pregnancies
if you don't want to increase your risk
of STDs and I would try to find a girl
and try to try to stick to a monogamous
relationship but if that's not something
you're worried about I mean obviously
you can make if anyone can make their
own choices and consensual and uh but
yeah and I think also like we mentioned
society and children's stuff but we
don't want to neglect like the self as
well like it's really we also think like
the importance of the self you don't
want to be miserable in a marriage and
you don't want to be just like oh oh I
gotta suffer through that's not what
we're advocating for I just hope that's
clear that like we're advocating for
like a really healthy relationship where
you're willing to grow of course and so
that's just something you don't often
see so we're at we're advocating for
like a radically different marriage than
I think right most are doing right which
is amazing and so important to say too
because it's it's and it's hard work
right you know it would be easier it
could be easier to be like at certain
times in your life right to be like is
this might be I think this isn't for me
but is that actually best is it best for
you is it best for you there's so many
things to question of if it is it's
actually best just because it doesn't
feel right in the moment you know and
being able to like work on the self and
that's where we come back to is like
working on the self for each other
totally to make your relationship
stronger yeah yeah you definitely got to
work on the self yeah that is the most
yeah I guess that yeah that was part and
parcel of the my monogamous relationship
was was we weren't working on ourselves
we were too
ingrained in in what the kids were doing
so yeah it's definitely important and
also ingrained in maybe like what you
aren't doing you aren't doing this right
instead of what am I not doing or what
am I doing that I can change because it
shape your communication shifts
completely with your relationship the
way that you communicate how am I
approaching a conflict it's just the
simplest things like that am I
approaching it on guard am I approaching
it like with my walls up am I having
this High negative energy am I being
prideful you know what like the pride
and the ego versus the facts of the
situation you know all that comes into
play of how your relationship unfolds
yeah I think if well you know I believe
in the Bible and I'd think of what God's
version of marriage is and what he
commands the husband to what kind of
husband he commands him to be to his
wife and it says you're supposed to love
your wife like Jesus loved the church
and what did Jesus do Jesus came to
Earth and he died for for everybody so
what are husbands called the dude
they're called to be like Jesus and if
Jesus was perfect so he's calling us to
Perfection that everyone had that desire
like I'm gonna try to be perfect for my
wife I'm gonna you know uh obviously
there's gonna be times where it's not
going to be perfect obviously but yeah
that's what the command is and that's
what we want to push for is I'll give
everyone on each side of the
relationship push to try to be the best
possible partner they could be and put
the other person's needs first if she's
putting my needs first then I'm going to
have my needs met and if I put her needs
first then her needs are going to be met
and we don't have to think well I have
to do this she's just automatically
going to do that obviously it takes a
lot a lot of work and a lot of people
aren't willing to put in that work or
you don't really realize that that's
that's when relationships work best one
is when both partners are giving their
full to the relationship because then
naturally your needs are gonna be met
obviously you have to have open
communication and honesty and all that
as well and that's where the fireworks
happen for us like when we are doing
that we're putting the other first we're
doing we are doing that exactly and
focusing on each other and loving each
other in that way that's when like our
bond is incredible and we're on fire and
when we're not when it's the selfish
selfish me what do I need that's that's
when it falls apart and so I think so
many relationships yeah we start
comparing like well I did this and this
and this what did you do for me yeah
it's not
my spot exactly
well that person she's doing
for me when really it's just because you
put your best self forward in the
beginning you know and then that the way
it ends up you just get more and more
comfortable and you get more relaxed and
that's where the relationships start to
where downhill totally Until you realize
that's not gonna help you you have to
continue to put your best foot forward
for each other and for yourself right
because then your fireworks are amazing
and you only need each other that's not
to say there isn't you know the obvious
reality is of Attraction but is that
good for our relationship we obviously
conclude them but you guys conclude
differently yeah absolutely and we just
want to say it I mean or me personally
but I'm so much of your lifestyle and
your home and your family together
inspires me tremendously and I think
it's so beautiful what you both have
created together in your family in your
home and the way you raise your children
and we want to carry so much of that
into our lives too so it's amazing it's
such an honor to sit here and have this
conversation with you too because we
truly value your opinion and see the
product of all of your work and
intention over the results excuse me of
all of your work and intention and it's
cool it's amazing to sit here and think
we're four different people and but we
want something so similar and also
different in our own ways and I guess
that's kind of what we can just end it
on or Advocate on is we believe it you
know there's there's room for everyone
on that Spectrum I said and um but
obviously love compassion Community
communication trust Foundation like we
we have so many of those same values as
well
differently yeah thank you we think you
guys are amazing I love the intention
behind your quality of life and wanting
to be your best version of yourself you
know I think it's amazing and I
appreciate like your respectfulness and
love and openness nope yeah I was gonna
see your openness and honesty and just
willing to just be yourself yeah so many
people are so guarded in conversations
and stuff so thanks for helping us of
course thank you so much thank you I
think we're good I think this is a great
way to end it cool thank you thank you
so much fun
[Music]